Hardcore got into this originally
through a former police officer who saw
need hmm
the challenges are obviously this is a
cash based business so what happens is
when I drop off cannabis
we're picking up cash okay so this is
the company hard car that you're
involved with right now correct how did
you get involved at these guys how did
you how did you start working for these
guys um initially I had wanted to get
into the industry obviously from an
advocacy standpoint goes to the military
guys to my buddies and really didn't
know how to get into it but after seeing
as we talked about a little earlier with
Vice land and there were security teams
were doing this kind of to look at that
model and see if it was something we
could do here in Florida right so the
challenge is that everybody wants to do
this the reality of it is that not
everybody can do this if we now vet all
of our guys so as you come in we do
federal background checks on everybody
I've had from pedophiles to guys who
told me they were Navy SEALs and
obviously you know both ends of those
that spectrum is not acceptable
especially prevent it if you're the
pedophile who can not been a VC oh
that's a problem my challenges were
finding guys that were who they said
they were - what a great temperament
bring them in to this okay kind of cool
in an emerging industry okay so we so
hard cars main objective is transporting
cash correct or is it also transporting
marijuana it's actually doing both okay
our vehicles are up armored are the new
ones we now have actually have AC units
in the back what does that mean up
armored up armored is basically a bullet
resistant okay so the front cab is the
windows are completely resilient to any
kind of gunfire than they would you try
to use in the vehicle at all Wow so
that's really to kind of keep the guys
safe mm-hmm and we that's our primary
objective here at the end of the day
right and it going through discrete so
if you looked at them it looks like a
sprinter man you would not have any clue
that that's what it is we run with the
windows are slightly tinted all of our
operations are typically done behind the
building so we try to stay out of the
way of the general public most the guys
are attacked out they carry rifles and
handguns and which always kind of looks
weird in front of a dispensary my name's
there so we dress a little bit different
we try to
you act a little different we're not
real aggressive we do pre trips to make
sure that if we're you know coming up on
a new place where they're located at
what's the crime rate in that area what
are the possibilities are somebody
trying to come up in jackets in the
middle of a either a cash offload or a
cannabis offload so it's it's the
reoccurring process of staying alert and
staying on your game so who are the
clients of hard car right now at out in
California there's about 6500 licenses
that are out there and each of the
dispensaries becomes a customer to hard
car so we we do a couple different
things differently than just a security
group so individual marijuana
dispensaries correct contract hard car
correct okay and we would again
transport their cash their product mm-hm
we can do the new right now new push in
California is for a product called flash
frozen its cannabis that is loaded into
a trailer
it's literally cryofreeze down to 20
below and what happens is they take this
then and bring it to a large press we
actually put it in our back of our
trucks the trucks have the ability to
refrigerate it yeah so it's hold a
temperature at about 19 degrees so we
transport this as an example we did
2,200 pounds when you start looking at
this and this is these are the groups we
try to align ourselves with Flo Khanna
is a distribution model in California
right now they're probably they're like
the Amazon right now they come up with a
bleed who is this again it's called flow
khanna flow Khanna okay look on out of
Northern California great group
distribution based and what we do is we
leverage our transportation against
distribution so if you say hey Mike we
want you to transfer our cash for us and
our cannabis for us or like great we'll
do that for you at no charge if you guys
let us handle your distribution so we're
a different security group that's really
where we make so now we're gonna save
you money on the processing cash where
hard car security is the first group in
the country to actually make a deposit
into the Federal Reserve and we continue
to do that today really so yeah and
again when you think about its federal
ego how do these guys do that well
there's a process to get that money and
obviously we drive up armored vehicles
that are certified up armored vehicles
which gives us the ability to so first
of all transport cash
anywhere we have a license to do this so
just in case anybody's out there whose
ears pop up when I say this but we gotta
for cash anywhere in the state or
anywhere in the country right cannabis
unlike cannabis that is federal
guidelines you cannot break state lines
with cannabis hmm
so there's there's a whole other side to
the federal thing with regards to hey
this is what we're gonna do we're gonna
transport cannabis I'm like if you
transport cannabis and you're breaking
state lines it's only a matter of time
before you get caught so you guys just
do like a long road trip and you'll hit
multiple dispensaries when you're when
you're dealing with cash it depends um
we we have set minimums on cash we would
pick up from your dispensary if you're
not doing a million plus when we stop in
because that's what we're there to pick
up probably not gonna be doing business
with you yet okay so we're looking at
that that threshold so we go to a
particular location so yes I have to
pick up a minimum of a million dollars
to be able to make it worth your while
correct okay correct and to make it
every worth wallet for everybody looks
right obviously more the less time you
know what creates crime is opportunity
the less times we touch this and carry
the larger amounts the less time we have
to worry about somebody coming more
aware of what our movements are right so
as we you know we if we're picking up
big cash we send a chase vehicle out as
well okay those guys arm they're behind
the vehicle typically in a suburban type
and it's it's it's gonna be noticeable
to some extent and we want that people
to realize that listen if you're gonna
try to get foolish here that you're
[ __ ] up things are in yeah yeah we
don't do the traditional you know fat
overweight security guy who is not
really taking this as a as a way of life
the guys that we employ this is a way of
life for them this is a their gun guys
to begin with they live a certain
lifestyle they're typically in great
physical condition they care about what
they look like these are the guys that
we're interested in
everybody can shoot a gun it's how well
can you shoot a gun how well you know do
you carry take care of yourself when you
look smart and you look like you're
somebody to be dealt with that sends a
message also that again keeps the bad
guys away from you right Wow
if you guys ever ran into anything
sketchy any problems or anything out any
trips yeah absolutely well listen one of
the one of the few things that obviously
many people don't do is when you pull up
on a particular location and you just
take a few minutes to look around
yeah and we've had guys actually
videotaping us we have had actually
individuals within the dispensary that
we were picking up stuff from
videotaping us and I was like Hello what
are you doing
and he was like oh dude I'm gonna put
this on Instagram I'm like oh my ass
you're gonna put this on Instagram so so
now we have to implement some new
policies and procedures with some of the
dispensaries making the understand
listen we're not trying to be a hard-ass
here but we don't want people to
understand what our movements are what
our vehicles look like and you know what
are we transporting today obviously if
we drop off three or four hundred pounds
of cannabis up to 2,200 pounds if you do
the math at $2,000 a pound that adds up
pretty quick it'll be the situation of
carrying 30 million dollars to a
particular location where now you have
to count that money we process it we
actually bag it up for the Federal
Reserve I think it's - it's amazing when
you see how many how many counterfeit
bills are out there so we have to now
these units automatically pull those
counterfeit bills out and we have to go
back to the end-user the customer and
say listen it was $300 in bad bills that
were here and by the way you don't get
those back there's go right back to the
Secret Service so it's it's crazy when
you really think of that in the bigger
picture but you think about how much
money you're carrying yeah and where
could you possibly get three million
dollars in one hit off of a truck on the
road today you know especially look at
the Brinks trucks the Dunbar trucks yeah
and so again we're looking to do that
long haul the state of Florida has
determined now there's two types of
Transportation you've got local delivery
and then what they actually call the
heavy haul and which just is the same
way that it sounds it's a heavy
transport for processing purposes again
1,000 pounds whatever that particular
number would be so what is that process
like to actually deposit all this cash
into the Federal Reserve so